This is a special moment for General Motors...
...as we reimagine the future of personal transportation...
...for the next five years and beyond.
Leveraging technology to create a consistent GM brand promise.
Vertical take-off and landing drone or VTOL is GM's first foray into aerial mobility.
We are preparing for a world where advances in electric and autonomous technology...
...make personal air travel possible...
It is a concept designed for the moment when time is of essence...
...and convenience is everything.
You've been at the office, and now you need to get to a meeting across town.
The VTOL meets you on the roof and drops you at the vertiport closest to your destination.
It uses a 90-kWh EV motor to power four rotors...
...as well as air-to-air and air-to-ground communications.
As a passenger, it represents personal space...
...and a panoramic view of the world passing beneath you.
And it's a glimpse of what autonomy and Cadillac luxury might look like...
...in the not too distant future.
We have other concepts coming...
...including a luxurious two-seater designed for you and someone very special...
...to decompress, relax and enjoy a multisensory experience...
...choreographed for more intimate journeys.
Each concept reflecting the needs and wants of the passengers...
...at a particular moment in time...
...and GM's vision of the future of transportation.